smoke rising over a Polish Village after
a blast that will be heard around the
world allegedly caused by Russian
missiles
Landing not in Ukraine but here in
Poland a member of both NATO and the
European Union
[Music]
emergency vehicles arriving at the scene
but this isn't about ambulances or
police officers it's about the
inflammatory Specter of Russia attacking
a NATO member we have a variety of
Methods at our disposal in terms of
verifying information
to include contacting allies and
partners to gather information and so
um again we're looking into these
reports and we have more to provide
we'll be sure to do so Russia has denied
any involvement saying in a statement
that it had launched no strikes in the
area it's described this as a deliberate
provocation in Poland the government has
called an emergency meeting to consider
its response the country has recently
called for much tougher action against
Russian aggression within NATO and
across Europe there are now calls for
Urgent investigations to confirm that
this really was a Russian missile to
discover where it came from and whether
it was deliberately fired into Poland
NATO could activate Article 5 a response
to an attack but it might be more likely
to turn to Article 4 which demands
consultation I think here there's enough
ground for triggering uh what is just
below Article 5 which is Article 4 which
is basically Poland asking all the NATO
members to come to the NATO headquarters
and to consult each other to assess the
threat and to take concrete actions both
anger and tension are now extremely high
Clarity and calm heads will be crucial
I don't pass in Sky News Brussels